ديسمبر عام 2019 كشف وثائقي الاسرار
الكبرى جماعه الاخوان اجتماعات بثتها
حصريا العربيه والحدث
كشفت عن اسرار تنظيم الذي حكم السودان
قرابه 30 عاما وكواليس انقلاب عام
1989 قضيه تعود للواجهه بعد افاده قضائيه
للبشير هي الاولى له منظر
الانقلابيه قضيه العسكريه لم تشارك فيه اي
شخصيه مدنيه او اي عضو في مجلس قياده
الثوره
كل المسؤوليه
عما تم في 30 يونيو
واعلم انه الاعتراف هو سيد الادله
اعترافات تتضارب مع تصريحات سابقه للبشير
في اجتماعات الشورى لما يعرف بالحركه
الاسلاميه تحدث فيها صراحه عن الدور
الكبير الذي منيح لجماعه الاخوان في
السودان ودورهم في انقلاب 89
التسجيلات الحصريه عن اهميه تسلم جماعه
الاخوان للسلطه بالطريقه التي يقررونها
اخواتهم واسالنا ما كشف عنه وثائقي
الاسرار الكبرى جماعه الاخوان كان
اعترافات بالصوت والصوره ليست للبشير فقط
وعلي عثمان طه النائب السابق للرئيس
المعزول الذي قاد في عليا المجموعه
المدنيه
ويشاركني زياده معظم يا اخواننا ان لم يكن
جميعا في الجنه انه بالمعطيات التي كانت
قائمه 89 لو عاد التاريخ القهطره فاثناء
نجف نفس الموقف وسنن بالتغيير الذي حدث
اقرار وعليه عثمان طه علانيه يرمز الى ان
الجماعه الاخوان كانت الحاكم المتحكمه وان
حزب المؤتمر الوطني يمثل فقط واجهه
للاخوان يتحكمون من خلالها علنا في الدوله
ومواردها
اول واحد الان هي دوله المشروعه الاسلاميه
التي يجب المحافظه عليها وان تكون
خياراننا وجهتنا منصبا للمحافظه عليها
للمفارقه كواليس حصريه للعربيه والحدث
تعود لاعوام تؤكد اليوم النظام المعزول هو
ناقد نفسه باعتراضات لا اسس لها تتزامل مع
ذكرى الرابعه للثوره التاسعه عشر من
ديسمبر عام 2018 التي اطاحت بالمشي